el techo de los alpes se derrumba la
sequía y las olas de calor provocan
enormes grietas y la caída de grandes
rocas en el montblanc a pesar del
peligro las vías para llegar a la cumbre
no están oficialmente cerradas pero ante
las condiciones precarias
los guías responsables de los visitantes
suspenden los recorridos en rojo para
que los guías como yo en sa money han
cerrado un poco la ruta ya que no
vendemos ascensiones al mont blanc es
más complicado ir allí no puede haber un
accidente allá sería difícilmente
explicable
la falta de nieve revela peligrosas
fracturas a esto se suma el calor que
provoca el derretimiento de los pasos de
nieve que ayudan a cruzar las grietas lo
que estimula los derrumbes
no no mide más de 10 o 12 pulgadas de
ancho lo que es realmente una locura y
un gran cambio si un gran cambio da
bastante miedo ver cómo está
desapareciendo el resquebrajamiento y la
pérdida de hielo es consecuencia del
cambio climático y hace posponer los
sueños de quienes intentan estar más
cerca de las estrellas
ellos cancelaron el viaje montblanc por
el clima creo que los guías conocen el
área y conocen las condiciones pero está
bien para nosotros podemos hacerlo en
otro momento delante
situada a más de 4000 metros sobre el
nivel del mar la cima de montblanc es
una meta para muchos escaladores
aficionados quienes ven su ascenso como
una prueba de resistencia y voluntad
ante las adversidades